(rock music)
- All right, I wanna share one more story
that might tug at your heartstrings.
Before we close the show,
this is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Usually on birthdays we're
used to getting presents,
that's the norm.
But one Iowa pastor is making his birthday
about giving presents
in the form of free gas to his neighbors.
He just finished his second year
and has filled tanks
for thousands of people
in his community.
We have him on the line right now
along with his friend who's
helping him with the project.
Let's say hi to Reverend Rob and Duana.
Hi.
(audience cheering)
- Hello, hello
- Hello.
Well, thank you for joining us
and how did this all come about?
- So first of all, Kelly, thank
you so much for having us.
One day, I was at a gas
pump a couple years ago,
and a young lady's card declined,
and I just went over and paid for the gas.
I went home that night and
I went to sleep, I prayed
and the next morning when I woke up,
I felt this unction and I called Duana
and I said, "Hey, I think
we should give away gas."
And that year we gave
away $5,000 worth of gas.
And then this year we gave
away $20,000 worth of gas.
And my friend has been
right there the entire time.
- Yeah, it was a pretty cool opportunity
for our nonprofit Des Moines
Urban Experience to step in.
We really believe in helping
people in our community
and uplifting their voices.
And when Rob shared with
me the vision that he had,
being his friend,
I wanted to pour into that
vision as much as we could.
We decided to team up and
really help our community
at a time when everyone's hurting.
And this was the perfect opportunity,
because everyone needs gas.
- That is so exceptional.
Thank you guys so much.
Everybody give it up for
Reverend Rob and Duana.
I'm liking your post right now, y'all.
And that's not all.
- Thank you so much.
- I know, we're not over yet.
The Lord's still present, watch this.
That's not all, our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like y'all.
So, they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 to help fill
even more gas tanks.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much, Kelly.
Our goal for next year, you
know, our presenting sponsor
which is the same gas station
as this year is coming back
and our goal is $40,000.
And so, we really do lean on our partners
and our community members
to help us raise this money
to go out and do it.
- Yes, thank you.
- Keep it up, y'all.
This is a really beautiful
thing you're doing for people.
It seems so simple, but
it's super effective.
You gotta get to work, so,
gotta take your kids to school.
Gotta have transportation.
So thank you so much and
thank you to all our guests
this hour, Niall Horan,
Kimberly Williams-Paisley,
Mika Pazinski, Tracy and Nancy.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, well, try and change it.